on this episode I give the most
compelling reason for you to finally
comment
[Music]
[Music]
ask Gary B
[Music]
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is a 180 on the ask gary be show
geez we've not been putting these out at
any kind of regular pace and it's kind
of pissing me off and I'm sure it's
pissing you all off as well I'm sorry
about that it has been busy with
vaynermedia and book world and dailyvee
we've been we kind of made a commitment
a couple weeks ago the rock and I of two
dailyvees and to askgaryvee spur week is
kind of what we're aspiring to do I feel
super unnatural we like a god we've like
done hardly any shows India I don't even
I was called you Africa because I don't
even like I don't remember your name you
know like I don't even know who you are
anymore in the I don't know you are guys
and all of you who love the show I want
to give you huge daps thanks for being
patient I'm super excited about doing
the show today I'm here tomorrow I don't
see it in my calendar not in my calendar
right I think I may try to sneak one in
tomorrow too because I just need it and
thank you for everybody that's been
supporting the book this would be a
great time to buy the book if you
haven't yet I really need it and if you
don't know about super 8 let's link that
up in right here and let's also link
that up on Facebook and YouTube copy a
super a big event February 23rd 10:00 to
6:00 p.m. Eastern right and oh no are we
doing it the court no we're gonna do it
here right we're gonna do right here a
telethon buy eight books lottery ticket
come to New York see me spend an hour
with me India let's see I don't even
know how to do this anyway let's let the
Shah
I'm fired up good good energy
I'm excited Facebook live what's up all
right let's go sonarak okay so now okay
trevenant golf ass no new twitter users
registered between October and Christmas
last year thoughts it's not no new
Twitter girls it's a net loss bad I
think I think we're working on a very
big Twitter piece when is that gonna be
done
oh we will use this answer okay
interesting it's very meta up in here in
180 um you don't think I think look I
mean I've been on this kick for a while
you'll see on tomorrow afternoon most
likely Monday because I know how these
guys roll we put together a very big
piece like we did with snapchat thank
you for everybody who shared actually
link that up if you haven't read the
manifesto for snapchat there was
incredible great work by the team we've
got one coming out for Twitter we want
to do these big signature pieces kind of
front cover stories more for the blog
and for you guys also big shout at
everybody so many people emailing me
thankful for the new VIP video only
contact we finally we've finally figured
out how to make my email service much
more valuable to people and I'm killing
the ruck I feel but I feel like 7 years
of angst to deliver on these videos
that's why it's going so well
so if you're not signed up for the
newsletter that's another right hook
actually lips just title this 180 right
hook books VIP emails sign up for
everything face look if you're watching
sign up for my youtube subscribe you to
preside over face.look twitter twitter
struggling people don't understand it
it's losing attention Instagram and
snapchat emerged as major attention
grabbers within mobile devices and I
think of all give me this phone I think
of all of my this is what I think about
I think this is the television and that
TV is the radio and it's 1965 that's
what I think I think this is the
television 1965 and TV is the radio
there's a lot of people that still think
the radio in 1965 was the place to
advertise and spend your time and energy
I don't believe that to be true anymore
I think this is the number one device
and I think that YouTube Facebook
Instagram and snapchat are ABC NBC and
CBS that's what I think is happening
with Twitter think of Twitter as MTV 10
years ago
it was there and think about me Gary Vee
being being one of the hits shows a
remote control no I'm very old very I'm
[ __ ] old but you know Jersey Shore
think of me Gary Vee on Twitter as on
Jersey Shore
Twitter's MTV this is the television
what I think has happened to Twitter is
that snapchat and Instagram have now
become ESPN have now become the hot
network and so that's what I think it's
happening to everybody right this second
on Twitter the reasons not growing is
because that network is not growing on
the television and I'm excited though
because much like how networks got
turned around the way that NBC the way
that CBS went from fourth place the
first place was they brought in new
executives who did better job
programming and so Jack Dorsey is now in
place he'll be making a lot of changes
and if those changes work Twitter can
rise but we've not seen it in tech
myspace wasn't able to rejuvenate itself
right we saw it a little bit with
Facebook there was a lull for a second
with Facebook and then they made a lot
of good tweaks and they like just
completely became the establishment I am
so intrigued by seeing what's gonna
happen but I think Twitter is dealing
with what they're dealing with my
ultimate thoughts are it's getting what
it deserved they didn't ID ate the
product for a long period of time and
they're paying the price little ocean
drop ass how can I use a diploma and
years of experience if they are in a
field
I don't currently want to work in LOD
there's a lot of things you can do you
can use your career and your diploma as
a proxy to people and show them that
you're able to accomplish things that
you have set your goals out to do while
acknowledging that you are now shifting
those goals in your life the truth is
nobody's gonna penalize you for making a
shift into a new arena
you just have to consider you have to
convince that decision-maker that all
the skills and dry
and talent that you deployed there are
going to be acceptable in this new world
you know let's just say for example that
you make your entire career living in
the wine business as a merchant and then
decided that you wanted to run one of
Madison Avenue's most premier digital
shops that would take some convincing
and you do that by commencing and then
you do it by doing and so much like many
people have had different careers and
they've gone from much like you know
what you're like the rock the rock was a
successful wrestler but we didn't think
he was going to be a superstar movie
actor until he did it so in the
beginning he had to commence
decision-makers directors producers
agents the market that he was capable
and then you get your at-bats I Marky
Mark is now one of the great successful
entrepreneur people his name is Mark
Wahlberg he's a superstar he's a
businessman we didn't think Marky Mark
was gonna cross over Justin Timberlake
was in a boy band with some curly ass
hair we didn't think he'd be one of the
great musicians of our generation or
some didn't so I would say that it's
very easy you just have to think about
this I think it's gonna be quite easy
for you to convince somebody to give you
a job or give you money for your startup
I think the next part is way more
interesting can you actually do it
because everything's built against that
just because you want to go into
something else doesn't mean you'll be
successful so if you feel confident and
assured that you can do it don't worry
about commencing and everybody just
convince somebody because then you're on
the record you just the convince one
person that you can make videos and then
you're on the record and then either you
make them and they're good or you make
them and they're [ __ ] that might be good
peace Nia commencing one person I did
that was he didn't see me come with that
right because it's such like in the
background right like you just know it's
like that was why I was a fun recall
it's nothing like a lot of people didn't
think I was gonna use myself as a proxy
because it's now accepted that I did it
but at the time
when I made the switch people were very
cynical the Mackay Twitter boy
running an agency against against all
these real agencies wide and candy and
OMD these are real companies these are
billion-dollar Madison Avenue madmen
companies and I was like those companies
and either I was gonna be too
egotistical and a flop and full of [ __ ]
or I was gonna be what I am beast I mean
that's what it was it's like hey Twitter
but I think business we came in wrote
like hey Twitter boy let's do it click
gear hey what's up Gary Michael Anthony
here I'm the creator of click your
clothing and I have a question for you
over the course of the last year I've
spent all my efforts trying to grow a
community of photographers around my
brand but I realized on order taken to
the next level I have to find a partner
or an investor but the problem is I have
this defensive wall up about asking for
help it's just not the way I was raised
my question is how do you get past that
man how do you take down that wall and
say hey you know what I need help and
then reach out to people I really
appreciate your thoughts on this thank
you so much that was so well done let's
have more of that you know we haven't
done this right hook in a while ask
questions there's so many of you that
are not asking I love when people tweet
like this is my eighth time getting on
the show you're right cuz you're a beast
also and you just keep asking yet the
98% of you have never asked a question
once use the hashtag on the comments in
YouTube Facebook Twitter or Instagram
because ok I'll give you every option to
get your questions in I'd like to get
some new people in here also I like what
we did with snapchat send me some
questions and I'll hand you my phone
tomorrow and you'll just go through some
of the video questions and maybe we'll
download them or what have you
Oh actually that's right ask your
question on snapchat to me directly then
download it cuz you can and then tweet
it I'd like to get some more snapchat
visuals in the show since we're Hana and
you can learn how to download in our
article my man first and foremost I'm
kind of bored by this question and let
me tell you why you just let your guard
down you are scared to ask or and I get
it because I also don't like asking for
help so I really connected with you by
the way in the black and white
video you just did you just put yourself
out there to a hundred thousand people
you just you just owned it so you're
good
really you're good you've now put
yourself out there Mayon took my comment
to you is go into youtube and facebook
right now and leave a comment so the
other homies of this community can find
you to say what you're missing is it the
financial part is the organizational
part like why don't you come to me like
yo that's me cuz I don't know your name
cuz it's just do you know his name got
it so but everybody know who you are
like and just be like here to six things
I want guys the dirty little secret
about the askgaryvee show and dailyvee
is if you become part of the community
you will win let me explain watching
each of you bizdev with each other in my
comment section this this silent
majority that watched the show and yeah
I'm trying to bring you out lurkers
today the silent majority of you are
making a huge mistake just commenting
and saying first time commenter in this
episode like what you've been doing or
answered the question of the day that I
come up with or what have you
we'll put you in the ecosystem for other
people saying hey because there's a
couple of extroverts out there so to you
my man directly I really need you to
like list what your what your
shortcomings are I have a funny feeling
15 people are gonna respond and say
they've got those strengths and you
might find your partner write my
comments section and for rest of you get
in this community
Serena ass you travel so much what are
your tricks and tips for overcoming jet
lag I don't have a trick I don't know
what's happening it's a it's called
enormous Lee lucky DNA I think if my
brain can out will a lot of things I
think when I get going I don't know I
just um I've just got it like that I've
got a lot of natural energy I showed up
with some people's podcasts over the
last couple days and a lot of people
leave comments like this guy's on drugs
so I'm super high energy I get it it's
so crazy
I've never even smoked a cigarette like
you know like so like it's crazy how how
lucky I am with my natural adrenaline
what
right and it's and it's real and it's
long it's real sustained for 18 hours
day every day every month every year
yeah Mike was even saying to me I landed
from I did the red eye and I landed and
then we worked out yesterday
and I had the best workout I've ever had
like Spratly got my energy he was just
literally like how the [ __ ] do you never
crash we're super behind that broke a I
got it when do I have to leave okay cool
all right we'll wrap up soon James
you're here for the all hands-on right
why don't I do cause I'm looking yeah
exactly I could do with them then I
don't want to hold him up awesome all
right Caleb oh this kid Hagar geomatics
here and my question is if the next 30
seconds of the askgaryvee show was
broadcast into all seven billion people
on this planet
what would you say thank you so much for
answer my question by the way I'm pumped
up to be speaking with you at Sydney
Australia to me off the charts the
charts the charts
Caleb what would I say that's a really
good question
if I hadn't iPad now Caleb this is
something you don't know I once four and
a half years ago explored and was
willing to put up my own money for a
Superbowl commercial and in the
commercial it was gonna say so I guess
this is probably already answered this
four years ago five years ago actually
before Vayner six years ago about six
years ago I tried to buy a Super Bowl
commercial for two million dollars my
own personal money like pretty much my
liquid at the time and I was gonna make
a commercial that says hey America it's
me Gary and I really want to be your
friend and I'm not kidding I basically
want to know you I'm into wine I'm into
business I need to know you here's my
handle it's Twitter at Gary Vee and I'm
gonna be sitting right now answering all
of you every one of you so that's what I
would probably do I would probably
replica and by the way the end of the
story was I had the money for that but
for all you media buyers you knew this I
didn't know it at the time if you try to
buy the Superbowl Fox or CBS or NBC
makes you buy another twenty million
dollars worth of commercials around the
year to even get access to pay two
million that I didn't have
and so and so Caleb and everybody else
what I would do is I would just create a
context point to let America know that
I'm a listener for all the energy you
know 20 I got a lot of feedback by
showing up on a bunch of podcasts the
last couple days and by asking how how
did you four I've been asking a lot how
did you first feel about me
when the truth is I don't make a good
impression with most people at first
because I curse and because I have ego
what they don't know is that I equally
have humility that I equally am NOT a
snake oil salesman that I'm equally a
tremendously good dude
so there's a very ironic thing with me
I'm not as big as I could be followers
selling books impact on the world
because of the way I come out again with
that energy with that competition love
with that bravado and I know that yet I
don't change because I think
authenticity will always win I'd rather
the amount of people that said they came
around to me in the comments section or
if you guys read the face book on this
or they Instagram like I first didn't
like you but then I kept hearing about
you I watched the second video third now
i watch the askgaryvee show I really got
to know you that's what askgaryvee has
been big for me you've gotten to know me
a lot better with this and dailyvee and
so um so that's what I do Caleb I would
just try to establish that I'm a
listener and I'd say hey what do you
want to talk about I'm here to answer
questions so it's what I would do that's
it great I'm gonna throw Caleb's
question at you because a good job
fourteen-year-old hustler that's a good
question what would you do if you had
all of America's attention for thirty
seconds during a Super Bowl spot you
keep asking questions I'll keep
answering them
[Music]